if you're not vegan you're treating
animals worse than the Nazis treated the
Jews what did he
say at Christmas time I always look
forward to a nice big ham on Christmas
day maybe a prime rib maybe you do the
ham and the prime rib but one thing I
know is I want lots of delicious meats
that drives the libs absolutely crazy
which is why I am so pleased to be
joined today by my friend Ben spell hey
the CEO and founder of good Ranchers Ben
thank you for coming in thanks for
having me thank you for all the
excellent meet you go to
goodranchers.com use code NES scream NS
into the void while you do it you can
get the greatest deals and the best meat
out there simple as that we're going to
see if these Libs can convince me a
conservative podcaster and you the CEO
and founder of a meat company okay to go
meat free in 2024 let's do it take it
away a lot of people ask me why I went
vegan and it's honestly because I was
tired of being a hypocrite I'm an animal
rights activist a woman's right activist
and an environmentalist and if you eat
meat you are none of the above how are
you going to advocate for animals and
then go ahead and eat chicken nuggets
after that it just doesn't make sense
how are you going to advocate for
women's rights and then you go and steal
a mother's child turn that into a
cheeseburger and then steal her milk
drink that for your breakfast some
people are like Sam that's not a woman
that's a
cow it's the divine feminine if it
canate create life I'mma protect that
lastly I'm an environmentalist right I
care about the planet Earth I give a if
we used all of the land and all of the
water and all of the resources used to
feed animals and use that instead to
feed humans oh my God the things we
could accomplish and lastly for
Spiritual reasons because how the am I
supposed to be an aligned meditative if
I am consuming a literal corpse that
died screaming that lived a life of hell
because energy transfers right it
doesn't destroy it just gets transferred
I don't want that whack energy going
inside of my body and honestly there's a
lot more reasons but those are just a
few of the most important ones and to
non-vegans that want to argue with me in
my comments you better watch out what
the you say cuz I clap back she seems
really at peace you know she doesn't
have any of that bad energy in her right
she's yeah you guys came out the gate
with that one I was not fully aware of
what we were doing here yeah that did
you find it persuasive no it's it's
ignorant at best I I kind of followed it
it was you can't support animal rights
which I don't uh and you know support
killing animal okay fine uh you can't
support women's rights that one was a
little weirder and she got into this
kind of kooky New Age like divine
feminine weird ult demon talk so okay
she has a different religious view than
than I do I wonder what her stance on
abortion is you know it's amazing yeah
these they care a lot about a little cow
or a Delta smelt when it's the human
baby a very different view well she
never said she was a humanitarian this
this is true in her defense but be
careful she will clap back she will clap
back yeah next one some of you just
don't believe that my dog's a vegetarian
we're going to see which one she likes I
don't force her to eat her salad we have
this really gross beef and then I have
this delicious green salad so this is
Bonnie she is my little vegetarian okay
now no no no okay there we go thank you
now no no it's not what are you doing I
think that gal was in on the setup I I
don't think that was a totally Earnest
video but it is true there a dog has
never chosen a piece of cabbage over a
slice of bacon yeah that would question
if it's the dog that did yeah right okay
next one if you're not vegan you're
treating animals worse than the Nazis
treated the Jews what
the and you are worse than Hitler and
should be imprisoned and given the death
sentence watch Dominion on YouTube to
see what you have been paying for this
is an absolute atrocity animals are the
most oppressed beings on this planet I'm
done with all your bull excuses it's
time to live vegan and stop paying for
this tremendous Holocaust that has been
happening for way too long now it's 2023
we should not be eating animal products
and we should not be giving bull excuses
as to why we should keep paying for
their rape torture enslavement abuse and
murder live vegan yeah hold on what did
he say
he kind of SLI that one in at first I
thought this was a parody but it's not
this guy's obviously serious I've heard
this argument okay from a serious person
namely Peter Singer he's the founder
really of the modern animal rights
movement though he doesn't really use
that phrase and he's a a professor of
philosophy at Princeton and he totally
defends abortion MH but he totally
opposes eating meat you know the kind of
thing you were referencing earlier but
his argument is a utilitarian argument
he says the reason to not eat meat is
because animals suffer and in order to
reduce the most suffering for the most
amount of sentient beings we need to not
eat meat yeah what say you they they
talk about the suffering of the animals
um there are some places that do it
wrong yeah totally totally everywhere in
the world there are bad things that
happen every day because there's not all
good people we live in a fallen World um
but by and large um happy cows taste
better these families are dependent on
being able to sell these animals at the
end of their life when they go to
harvest them if you abuse the animals
the marbling is not going to be there
they're not going to get as much money
for them so they are diligent to treat
these animals right I mean there's also
just what they slip in there is this
conflation of human beings and animals
but we're distinct from animals right
and even they would acknowledge there's
this fundamental difference because they
don't think that we should put a cow on
trial for biting a child they don't they
don't think that we should put a gorilla
on trial for violating some abstract
concept of Justice because animals are
not able to conceive of Justice in the
abstract so there's there's that and
then there's just the the the error of
their moral reasoning which is it's
utilitarian that is not a proper view of
ethics it's certainly not the Christian
view it's not the traditional view in
our civilization where we view the
goodness or Badness of an
on thetion itself and so we recogniz
there's nothing immoral in killing an
animal certainly not for our own food
the people making these videos are have
no idea they've never been on a farm
they've never been on a ranch they they
have no clue even what they're talking
have they ever interacted with a cow
they ever like walked up to a cow
probably not probably not probably okay
next one sing eating animals WR
McDonald's hurting animals WR McDonald's
share
song and change your entire men to be V
from now
on okay the pitch was pretty good odd
I'm not saying the song was good her
pitch was surprisingly good uh the point
and the the lyrics were not great yeah
eating animals is wrong McDonald's now
In fairness too I don't know how much of
McDonald's meat is actually technically
meat you know I imagine there's right
right but I guess my question to someone
like her is why is it wrong I've never
heard a coherent philosophical argument
as to why it's wrong to eat me yeah well
the first girl her her thing was um
cruelty to animals like suffering yeah I
I talk to a friend of mine who's a
farmer and the animals are all pretty
happy he said they only have one bad day
in their lives it happens to be the last
one that's exactly right otherwise they
they have really nice lives that's
exactly right and and CS Lewis made this
point in I think it was in M
Christianity he said you don't want to
be cruel to animals we we don't want to
be cruel to animals at all that deadens
our Humanity it it cultivates really bad
vices and habits but you can be very
nice to animals and very kind and
gracious to animals absolutely and eat
them absolutely right it's the way it
should be yeah the whole vegan movement
the paa the these all of these um groups
that are anti-meat so let's call it the
anti-meat movement they have done an
amazing job of of dehumanizing the
farmer the family farm and what people
don't realize like because one of the
girls that first girl she said it a cow
and then a cheeseburger and what she
doesn't realize is there's two years of
raising that cow by a mom a dad and
their kids um 700,000 independent farms
and ranches in the US and the average
herd size is about 50 really that's yes
and nobody knows these these stats
because they've done a great job of
erasing the Family Farm taking the face
from the farmer and uh and just putting
in your head that there's a cow we don't
know where it came from it goes into a
factory with smoke and out comes a steak
or out comes a cheeseburger right and uh
we're so far removed from our food
supply as uh as a society and that's how
you get these videos like this let's
watch another one okay this is fun
right you going to eat that well yeah I
just get my sauce you shouldn't be
eating meat it's not meat it's chicken
no it's meat that's wrong a heartbeat it
had a life it had a soul yeah but it
doesn't have it anymore though no
because people like you are eating me
we're outside of KFC sorry we're outside
of KFC love yes I know which is why I'm
here trying to educate people like you
about
me yeah you're you're wearing a l jacket
this is vintage wait what this is
vintage okay it it was killed many many
years ago before veganism or before any
of this was was you know came to light
yeah I'm not going to throw away
perfectly good jacket it's cold out here
perfectly good chicken I'm hungry out
here but
people like you cows are dying because
the
jacket God no no I'm not going to be
eating why flesh it's not flesh it's
fried it's not flesh it's fried that
can't be real do you think that's real
it might be real I don't I don't I don't
know she gave a compelling performance
anyway and plenty of these vegan
vegetarian types ignore their own
hypocrisy when it's convenient to them
but the the part that really struck me
there she goes is an animal it has a
soul and he had the great says yeah not
anymore I guess the issue with all of
these arguments and videos is they
anthropomorph the animal they they seem
to believe that animals are just like
humans when anyone who's ever met an
animal knows they're not you know it
actually reminds me of in the Old
Testament when Israel left and what did
they do they turned to baale right they
turned and worshiped a golden calf now
we're seeing the libs worship actual
calfs and some of us enjoy eating those
calfs as ve especially the Italian
people we really like a good ve I don't
know I don't want to get greedy when can
I look forward to ve I look I'm I'm an
Italian boy in
America yeah um yeah as we continue to
grow We Will We Will continually be
expanding our product line amazing I got
one for you okay um so two uh vegan and
a vegetarian standing on the cliff
debating on who would hit the ground
first so they both jump off
who
wins all of us Society Society I knew I
knew it was going to be somebody like
that thank you for coming in thank you
for your excellent product and your
support of the show you're very welcome
and we will see you after I have my
delicious Christmas ham let's go for
it